and we're back hello everybody
what is that what is up another edition
as Sims and left go it is that beautiful
Monday May 21st weather out there Sims
there we're stuck only for a little bit
but I mean the day is bright you're
wearing a maroon shirt we're all happy
I mean is it unbelievable what did you
just tell would eat up only by Maroon
your marketing is top button swag I like
to stick to maroon there's a pattern
what a maroon
I love maroon do you not like the color
I've actually never seen you wear the
color Maru I have a few things like I
have a sweater Arun and olive those are
my two colors yeah but you can get away
with it maybe more than I can on thanks
I roll and your your your get a little
darker complexity I am so white
sometimes colors like that looks stupid
up when I was a sports news reporter in
Kentucky they had this consultant this
woman come in and they said bring all of
your clothes that you wear on television
and we're gonna help you with your look
and I was like okay so I brought all my
shirts and all my ties I laid him out
and it's yellows and pinks and baby
blues and she goes what are you doing I
go I love these colors she goes no no
your dark red dark blue I was like okay
fine so I through then you're the
opposite you're all pinks and yellows
and baby loses I am and definitely that
you would look good in those colors too
they look ridiculous I like your
sneakers Thanks they're almost as cool
as my peas but I'm wearing aeramax 270
freshest kicks yeah thanks you get down
the Royal Wedding you were all about it
man I liked when I woke up in the
morning I'm not gonna lie I woke up
let's say what was that Saturday morning
yeah my little boys baseball game got
canceled and that's a good thing as a
parent it was a good thing it was nice
to be able just like I could sit here
and drink this coffee and screw my kids
I don't have to worry about watching
them that's what I thought doing soft
pitch baseball or go to all great
it was strike 72 great head but you
watch sorry yeah yeah it was it is
amazing just I'm amazed by just the
wealth the architecture yeah the castles
yeah all that stuff I don't really care
about like the royalty being married or
anything I say this it was a cool event
it's really not cool when you're in a
relationship though because it's like
ooh
people are like taking notes oh I should
have that at my wedding yeah like they
had 40 million dollars of security okay
it's not realistic George Clooney and
Serena are and showing up yeah
just it's it's crazy it's another world
it feels like a travel back into time
but yet it's a great look into the
future progress progress yes and
England's being made man yeah that's
cool it was cool it was cool to see
English embrace the you know
african-american culture a little bit
and and you know really I thought I was
like he went out there and started
speaking about dr. Martin Luther King
and I was like I I don't know how well
versed all these Old English people are
and they seemed they seemed cool cool
you liked her dress I guess so I don't
know it wasn't like my I wasn't blown
away by it what is our topic is players
not getting you saw Avengers all
Avengers yeah we talked about it yeah it
was a good game shocker
who's the Thanos of the NFL shocker oh
the Thanos of the NF yeah probably like
Richard Sherman what I don't know no
like the guy that construed I feel like
Belichick is the fattest I guess so or
it might be Goodell yeah I was thinking
of somebody with a little more physical
might I mean Denis did beat the crap out
of the Hulk the Hulk game he made the
Hulk scared to come out yeah that was
pretty host the hell the Hulk saying no
what's going on here did your kids cry
no but they were shocked like literally
when they when the screen went by room
venez they took their glasses off and
looked at me and they said that's it and
I was like yeah I was like man I was
like we're not used to the Avengers
losing are we yeah and my wife was like
I gave you boys over your kids like
questioning everything that was
all right they handle it they handle it
okay that's honestly what I thought
about when I watched Avengers was how
our little kids could handle that yes
because for me I'm like yes let the hero
died I haven't seen this story before
but kids like as a parent it's gotta be
I'm gonna show my I'm gonna show them
how to battle through adversity they're
gonna think they're gonna lose and
they're gonna win and we go home and we
learn about trying hard yeah well not
losing is part of the world sorry
reality check join it I don't care
avengers teaching lessons we have a lot
of stuff to get to today in terms of big
names not being at OTAs and I just want
to tap into Sims as big brain and go is
this for real or is this something small
so we have Brady Odell Aaron Donald and
Julio all really interesting
conversations I got some whoa big
offseasons and we got that swag tastic
guys that just have ridiculous
ridiculous swag let's start off first
show me the money Tom Brady skipping
OTAs oh no is this serious or is this
just an 18-year 19 year veteran tired no
this is serious there's no serious
there's definitely stuff there yes there
I know that I know that and I don't you
know well I know there's talk to human I
have talked to humans I don't know all
the particulars of the story as far as
Jimmy Garoppolo Tom Brady all of that
yet the trade all the stories we've
heard through Seth wickersham yeah all
that stuff but I've got little Inklings
of the story here and there all right so
show me your nut will so first thing I
think we have to talk about is that me
gives a crap if if he's there or not
there at OTAs I mean it's don't worry
Tom Brady's gonna be able to throw the
slant route next year and the post route
and the end cut he'll be fine it's not
his first rodeo
he understands the offense and he's
gonna be prepared and ready to bat for
anyone that says but he's a leader of
the team we just went through this last
year Fletcher Cox didn't show to OTAs
the biggest thing was he's a leader on
the team right they were fine Oren
Donald that whole storyline is [ __ ]
yeah I'm more curious the they're still
issues in there yeah there's definitely
issues and and and yes of course I know
people
connected to the situation in the
situation and I don't have all like I
said all the details of some puzzle
pieces but I do have some puzzle pieces
and the basically what I was I've been
told really over the last like three
weeks when it's just come up in
conversations with people I had is that
yes that that Belichick was starting to
push the narrative inside the building
of maybe this should be the last year
for Tom Brady as in less and maybe we
should start to go forward with Jimmy
Garoppolo here for the betterment of the
organization for the next 10 years going
forward and I think that was something
that maybe he was hoping for whatever
and these are little details I don't
have yet yes
but nonetheless and then what I've been
understood at this point too is that
word got back to Brady basically word
got back to Brady that this was being
floated around in the organization
that's where he butts in and gets him to
mr. Kraft and finds that and goes I'm
gonna play three to five more years you
know do something about this basically
whether that's change trade Jimmy
Garoppolo or get on Bill Belichick but
that is the basic outline I have
received you know again like I said I
don't know all facts I don't know if I'm
ever gonna know all the facts but all
the stories I've been told are along
those lines so you're hearing that word
was going around that Belichick was
saying last year was the last year for
Brady yeah Tom hurt went to the owner
yeah said no no no and the owner went to
Belichick and said trade Garofalo pretty
much yeah my question is on machine
please Belichick talking to that it
would get out guys know the image of
Belichick in my mind is the ultimate
secret keeper yeah I mean the garage
door that locks his draft board
preference exactly I mean who knows
maybe it was the crafts that told but
Tom who knows because that would be the
one that I would think that he goes to
Robert goes to Robert here's my plan for
the future right I'm gonna say that this
is the last year of Tom and then we're
gonna go to Jimmy and we're here playing
and then Robert was like my son to this
is a bill saying to you Tommy and then
Tom was like dad
he went a bit longer yeah this is a
common mistake coaches make with players
that are involved in their organization
too long they forget that they have
relationships around the organization
too they forget that has it happened to
me with like my spleen thing in Tampa
you know there was being things spread
around the organization whether that was
from Gruden or people just not what kind
of things well whether it was a document
that went out about not discussing my
spleen there my injury and anything like
that so there's no legal ramifications
but people in the organization liked me
and they'd been around for six years and
you know me I'm a nice guy I'm pretty
Pleasant everybody and people came up to
me and started telling me what was going
on and behind some of those meetings and
I want to be you know I wanted to be
like damn yeah people like me too and of
course that's gonna happen in New
England this is making me think so right
right whenever we see a retirement tour
we always see the guys get away with a
lot more when Kobe's go on the
retirement tour or these baseball
players it's a big celebration they can
say things that we don't care Francesa
get away with murder fall asleep at the
radio station we're just happy to have
you yeah what if all of the leeway that
Belichick was giving Brady his own
trainer his own thing well because he
knew in the back of his mind that tom
was going to be gone after this year and
now all of that leeway has been turned
against him because Tom went behind his
back and got three four more years out
of it it's an interesting concept I mean
that kind of pettiness would go on on
the NFL's certainly yes and you know
also I think within all that and that
story and then of course Malcolm Butler
and the Super Bowl and players are
definitely disappointed by that I I
think the other thing is of course Tom
Brady I do think the contract situation
is real this time what do you mean I
just think that he's got to be looking
at a gun Dam we've talked about him not
being appreciated which was the guy that
is his friend setting up the
conversation I plead the front so he's
definitely yes he signed off on that
question right he doesn't feel
appreciated right so we know that I mean
if you're just gonna we're gonna play a
Jedi Mind Tricks and try to read between
the lines yes they're not appreciated
because of your salary or because the
way you're treated yes and his salary
he's not a
five paid quarter and I think he's gay
here in recent in recent past for seeing
a guy that again and Super Bowl 51 he
spotted the guy a 25-point lead and he
came back to win the Super Bowl be the
MVP be the first time quarterback we
have five Super Bowls and then follows
it up this son the next season with an
NFL MVP and he goes what I'm being paid
half as much as that guy I played
against the Super Bowl v you want to
beat yeah Matt Ryan gets a hundred
million dollars in Tom Brady goose gotta
eat at him I don't care I mean this is
again where I want to go do you want him
to be a competitor cuz Tom's a
competitor and he wants to be paid like
he's so I think a better comparison
Brady is breeze right breeze gets you go
thirty million dollars and then thirty
million dollars the next year not
guaranteed but it's really 30min dollars
right embrace what but Brady's sitting
at like probably eight I can look it up
as we're sitting here let me do it like
1819 something like that it's right
around that area and he's he's you know
he's always praised as being someone
that gives me a salary is 14 million
this year his cap head is 22 million so
how do you think this ends Tom Brady
he's gonna end up coming back or do you
think that they end up giving him new
contract yeah I think that checks not
gonna do it but Kraft could do yeah I
think they're gonna find some way to
sweeten the pot for him and Gronk at
some point here to give them a little
bit more money at some point he will
either get to training camp a day early
and he'll have a talk with Bill yep I
don't think it'll ever be like rosy Reds
but they're both gonna be professional
and go let's go win number six because
they are and they're probably in my eyes
I look at as Ben Brady over tired a year
for two they won't talk for four or five
years it's gonna be like Montana and
Bill a little bit and then they're gonna
go dim we were awesome together and
let's whack SPO ethically any
relationships between Hall of Fame
coaching quarterbacks that really last
the test of time it's not like Terry
Bradshaw let's think about a Chuck Noll
gave him a tough time right yes Chuck
not how Chuck Noll yeah Bill Walsh truck
got rid of Joe Montana like three years
trying to replace I'm with Steve young
many times before that Jimmy Johnson
didn't like Troy Aikman
I mean because there's this ego for guys
that are successful
and they all think that they deserve the
credit I was talking to my Patriots fan
Ruby over the weekend he goes but
doesn't Belichick realize that Tom Brady
has a little bit of time left and I said
well Ruby shouldn't Brady realize that
Belichick has a little bit of time left
like everyone thinks that you should be
focusing on Brady's you see and I'm
going if I'm a Patriots fan I am giving
a lot more credit for the five Super
Bowls to build Palecek than I am Tom
Brady yeah now I don't have a 12 jersey
I'm not a Patriots fan but Belichick is
sitting there going I thought Garoppolo
gave me the best chance for the next
five years
Brady maybe gives me the best chance for
the next two right right I think Bell
chicks thinking about his legacy but no
one thinks about his legacy they only
think about Brady's no it is it's more
of a player thing legacies you're right
about that and you know again not to
paint villain any bad picture here I
mean Bill's doing his job which his job
always was is to worry about the New
England Patriots football organization
and win games not now but in the future
it set his team up for those things so
yeah it's an interesting position
Patriot fans are in because yeah I
understand you want Brady one or two
more years and you remember the jersey
right exactly there was no Bill
Belichick hoodie with his name on the
back at the NFL shop no but do you know
the problem is what the Patriot fans
might have to deal with which I don't
know but if Brady does retire a year
from now or neck you know you're not
nearly as a good at position as you
would have been set up for success for
the next 10 to 12 years if you had kept
Jimmy Garoppolo
yeah I think that's the bottom line and
that's that's always a tough thing in
sports I think that's my question now is
of all the rooms that you could be in
during this Patriots issue yeah I think
my room would be I want to be with Kraft
and Brady and I want to I want to hear
who's complaining who's whining what's
the plan are they game planning against
bill right mr. Kraft is gonna be like
the babysitter here he's gonna try to
make sure they mend the relationship to
be successful working he's gonna come on
come on let's say you know one more
hurrah here you know it's it's the
benefit for everybody not only the money
with the legacies of both whatever the
organization all of it it's really
interesting it is it's faster than you
think Brady gets
more money and he ends up showing back
up for training yes I know TAS really
don't matter not not to Tom Brady come
on it's your nineteen trust me he's got
it all down all right so we know that
Brady and Belichick have swag so let's
play that swagtastic what movie am i
quoting there that's wag TS Takei just
changed fantastic okay first one is
tyree kill ya this man has swag we do a
lot of speed drills tyree kill says guys
are calling me out left and right it's
too easy
he just races guys all summer and he
says like smoke him he got really upset
that he's only a 97 in Madden yeah and
actually reached out to the video game
to try and get it up to 99 I have spoken
with someone at EA I'm the fastest in
the league you know what I'm saying
I need my credit he let's start there
though right is Tyree kill the fastest
NFL player currently in your mind
alright so it's in the two position
groups right it's a receiver in corner
that's it's all there is to no one else
there's no running back that I think no
put in that class right now right I'm
not missing there's no CJ 2k types no
I'm just trying to think off the top of
my head but ya know so it's a receiver
or a DB issue right D B's right now you
know who we gonna put in that
conversation I don't have tricked
Peterson but I think he I don't think
he's as fast as he's there like jaylen
Rams he can still fly I don't think he's
that fast know if he is either he's
deceiving he's a long Strider yeah I
don't know if there's any D bees there I
think I think of John Ross the wide
receiver for Cincinnati Jake is around
the fortwo great and I think of which
person there's one more that's a good
one I think a marquise good no I was
gonna say literally like an Olympic
hundred meter dash yes exactly right I
mean he's got phenomenal explosion the
type of C but I do think that Tyree
kills the fastest in the NFL Odell
Beckham jr. I would put never sure I
would definitely put in the race but I
would say Tyree killed from my 37 years
of football let's just cancel out the
first five when I wasn't really watching
and to intuitively
Tyreke conversation for the fastest ever
really I mean I don't know
I've seen anybody on the field other
than Dion faster than Tyree kill on the
field on Sanders green Darrell Green
Randy Moss in the early years maybe Bo
Jackson and I'm trying to think if
there's anybody like Willie Gault
remember from the old Bears team it was
also a 500 sprinter those would be the
guys that he's in the class of it I mean
it's that kind of a speed I don't know
if anybody can beat him in the first 10
yards it's the quickest explosion that's
the thing that you might have over ever
yes is there any Massa strides my give
him an advantage Deion Sanders long
speed was incredible but Tyree kills
ability to catch a ball at a standstill
and separate in 5-year old speed and
three stats the fact that he's able to
have multiple clips of him running past
people with a peace sign yes yes you
know so far ahead of people right Devin
Hester might have been in this
conversation in his prime because I
thought I know I've told you what my
Texas friends that were on that Chicago
team with Devin Hester I mean Nathan
Vasher who was well like a 4-3 he ran a
forward three was one of the fastest
guys that was ever around and he had a
hundred nine yard kick return for dad
remember we returned the Hubble and I
remember just coming man Nate's gonna be
amazing returning above on the next year
he was benched there's a return of her
Devin Hester and I was like what
happened he's like he was like man Sims
man you never seen David Hester whoa
that [ __ ] could run whoa I'm
telling you like run run I can't believe
that Nathan Vassar and Kermit the Frog
in this thing I like that a little bit
my friends know all-state Nate what up
he also went on to say this he oh he's
catching passes from Patrick mahomes and
everyone can say can throw far yes he
was asked Ken Patrick mahomes out throw
you and Tyreke Hill said there's no
quarterback who can overthrow me it's
not even possible
I see for me yes I would like to see
Patrick mahomes and Tyree kill and
bachelor homes ago I'm going to throw
this as hard as I can
yes let's see if Tyree can catch it that
that's fun to me he can midnight they
should do for the Pro Bowl is it should
be okay you throw it at ten yards right
and our quarterbacks gonna see if he can
out throw you right and it's just like a
nerf like because what people like like
guys like Tyree kill or big-time
receivers whether that was Joey Galloway
who I played with or Roy Williams come
out of Texas they have that true speed I
will say this about all great researcher
gala we didn't say I did I said Joey
they have the ability to go to another
gear when the balls in the air then you
don't even think they had and that's
usually where they run by TVs like we
had the same with Joey Galloway that
highlight you showed last week if he's
even he's leaving yeah because when the
ball was in the air he was able to put
his head down and go to another gear
that the DB's were not able to go do
Tyree kill has that gear it's special by
the way go to Sims and left go Instagram
and check out I posted a minute
highlight of Sims in the playoff game
against Washington your throw yes the
amount of people that were like that was
beautiful I didn't know Sims could throw
like that I III wish Sims could play for
my team no it's so funny that no one
really knows yeah but your throw to eat
Al Shepard spiral perfect spiral yep
I know that was a good one that's a
shame that won't hurt me forever
damn yeah hey you got the edge you Dovan
the end zone it looks like an athlete
those cool things man you know now
you're stuck here with me one more swag
dearest extract Diaz dick Dante Jackson
yes
cornerback drafted by Carolina out of
LSU which really station yeah I was I
didn't want to say him because I knew
who's gonna get to him guy but the S&L
issue should stand for swag he said it's
he was asked about trash talk and I took
the best quotes from this article
because there were like 10 quote it's
hard not to talk back to me because I'm
just gonna keep going Jackson said
they'll get used to it though so Dante
Jackson's gonna be talking a lot of
trash next year I'm happy about that
he's on the right team yes the Panthers
talk trash he says I play with
confidence I'm gonna talk about it walk
it like a talkin I can tuck it well so
he obviously likes the migos and he
ended like this too asked if he learned
how to talk he said nah I was born Oh
Dante Jackson we got I'm gonna keep my
eyes on we got ourselves a little
swagtastic guy down there in Carolina
I'm excited for ya they needed him they
got rid of Josh Norman they needed a guy
yes you got it I gotta have that guy and
he's a human missile I mean he is he
will be in the conversation for fastest
guy in football
he was one of my favorite guys in the
draft I mean again he was a hundred and
seventy eight pounds nickel corner and
people always always 178 pounds but yet
the fourth pick of the draft was 180
pounds but that was no problem with that
that's what I that's what drives me
toward you he's 180 was 2 pounds heavier
but there was no problem with that
weight but Dante Jackson there was a
problem as do pounds we're very
selective yes with our other courses
exactly right but man he is gonna be
perfect fit for them to I mean he's an
ultimate nickel back in the NFL which I
think there's more value than other
people do he can't guard the outside
guys yeah they do I don't come what is
it LSU got some cool guys and then I got
a lot of cool mother yeah I would say
it's a little bit of culture I'd say
it's also like a history of success and
I think it's the Legion given freedom
yeah the region to yeah I mean just
think about it who we talkin like cool
honey badger
Jarvis Jarvis Landry which one Patrick
Peterson trick Peterson I know there's
so many we're not looking elsewhere for
Netta swag yeah Quan Alexander damn
there's so many more there's such a
baller we should do that though
sometimes like pick the colleges we
should officially make seat like
cornerback you QB you and like vote on
it we probably should start doing that
stuff anyways we're like I mean it's not
like we're gonna have a million stories
here hey we could do that kind of stuff
are you doubting my ability no I know
that's keep it going because when
there's stories like Johnny Manziel
signing with the CFL only cares enough
material do you give a [ __ ] I didn't
mean to come off that strong Joe sorry
do you care this is the story about
Johnny Manziel she just started doing
News made noise let me get my camera
really quick this is how people do
Johnny Manziel Johnny Manziel has signed
with the Canadian Football League
proving that he wants to prove himself
to the NFL he'll likely go there for a
few months
show that he can handle the rigorous
schedules of the Canadian Football
League and then likely sign with a team
NFL teams are willing to say that
they're gonna keep an eye on Johnny
Manziel until he's ready to come to the
league that's the story that I hear all
the freaking time yeah
yeah does it really matter that much to
NFL teams is this really the proving
ground you've always said is this the
point to prove himself it's the only way
he's gonna be able to prove himself I
look at what is the NFL view of the
Canadian Football League that it's
there's some hidden gems up there and
that there's they're playing football
it's a little different rules but
there's pliers up there that have been
slipped through the cracks it's gonna be
constantly evaluated I mean when I was
in New England I to make tapes of
Canadian Football League guys is their
practice schedule game watch all that
stuff is it similar to an NFL week yes
it is okay so that's important yes it
definitely is I mean you're gonna be a
total he's not to be a professional and
I think that's where it's gonna go and
then also would like the CFL rules I
think you have to be there for like two
years right so he can't just leave after
one year stop he has to be there for two
years which is good it's gonna take not
one good year is not gonna go the NFL's
at all he's good timeout so you're
telling me he can't just leave I don't
think so I think is that even big it's a
two-year commitment as part of the CFL
be break contracts all the time yeah I
don't know I don't know how it works but
I'm pretty sure that's it if anybody
wants to look that up
like I'll look it up Manziel will make
Canadian Football League
must watch TV now he's fit for it he's
made for Canadian football my way it's a
wideout open field it's a wider field
it's a wider field it's gonna be the
longer end zones it's more of a passing
league isn't that benefit every
quarterback what it does but I'm just
saying he kind of benefits more from the
wide open football game anyways that's
what we saw him succeed with in college
football and this the one thing if you
go oh what are they lacking up in
Canadian speed especially big guys with
speed so he's gonna be able to roam wake
is our one guy we always talk about Oh
Wade came for the cable one we're
talking about one pass rusher and I know
there's more than I say about fifth
round draft picks you can find one the
fifth round right I know it's it's an
overstated line so yeah they're guys
from Canadian Football League that
played defensive lines a few but it's a
very short list and camera makes really
funny times yeah I was thinking all
these stories about Johnny Manziel 'he's
gonna have to prove that he can handle
it was going to be about meeting rooms
and practice schedules an actual better
talent no the real reason is can you
stay in Canada
for two years and not [ __ ] that's that's
the question litmus test
can you go can you do can you go two
years and we don't hear you're late for
a meeting or you were late for something
because we found you on social media
partying the night before all those
things are what the NFL wants to see for
him so yes he's got to go up there too
and he can't just go up there and be
like Oh middle-of-the-road Canadian
Football League no needs to be in Crimea
stupid ugh fluid exactly right if he's
Doug Flutie he gets a chance to come
back in the NFL small guys can't even
escape Doug Flutie can immerse them when
they go anywhere that's gonna be yeah
I'm interested he's playing for the
Hamilton tiger-cats so make sure to
subscribe to their stream Jim Joe I'm
curious is that who's there June Jones
is the coach right so he's going to a
super spread off in the run-and-shoot
which is gonna be tough too he's gonna
get destroyed the run shoot stuff that's
a lot of hits it does because it's about
the quarterback and the receivers always
the routes can change on a play-by-play
basis according to the great coverage
it's so it's a lot of that vending and a
gun and in an age of disguising cover
you have mistakes I'm just curious how
often he's gonna be hanging out with
Drake up in Canada I know but where
exactly is Hamilton man you ask the
wrong guy don't look it up okay fine I
mean look it up okay someone back there
look at but do you think he last the two
years does Johnny Manziel have success
in the cut in the CFL both as a
disciplined human and as an athletic
quarterback to get into the NFL will he
get into the NFL after this Chris Sims
hmm I haven't even thought I'm gonna say
no I'm gonna say no I know I don't
believe it I don't believe some tat like
success up there there's just something
in me that thinks it's gonna be not a
big enough stage for it to keep him like
what do I want to say interested he's
gonna get bored with the amateurism of
it to a degree and the fact that it's
not a main stage type of program and
he's gonna that's what I think I don't
know he's got to prove it to me I'm not
saying it will happen there's just more
on the human side there's more on the
human side right now yeah I got a I got
a see at least a year before I can go oh
yeah he'll come back he's finally on the
right
no right now I don't buy it all the way
I think that's my thing too is we've
seen this so many times with him before
where it's this is it this is gonna do
it and he has a few good months but then
after that he gets a little bit bored
yeah just as any human would
so I'm looking the distance between
Hamilton Ontario Canada and Toronto
Ontario Canada is 56 minutes okay look
and the truth thing is is I want Johnny
Manziel to achieve whatever he wants to
achieve I'm just now that I know that I
have to wait two years I'm not then he
has to I'm not it's a long time I don't
know two years no I know and I didn't
again I think it's actually a good thing
for him because I don't think a year is
gonna do the trick to where like NFL
head coaches you make oh okay he was
good up in Canada for five months so
let's bring him back right one guy that
I think is judged just like Johnny
Manziel except he could be one of the
greatest wide receivers of all time
right he's Odell Beckham oh they are
friends they hang out and they have
supported each other I didn't know that
you haven't seen I feel like Johnny
Manziel was such a star yeah that it was
like LeBron Drake Odell like I feel like
they were all together you know what I
mean like no Johnny Manziel during that
time could have hung out with anybody he
was all like no would have gotten that
invited right yes
you know Von Miller like he's friends
with everybody yeah but Odell Beckham
shows up to OTAs I see that Jordan right
on point one of the reporters for the
Giants talked about why he was there and
he said something to this nature the
Giants wanted Beckham present this
spring to show his dedication and see
firsthand how he has progressed after
breaking his ankle in October they got
what they wanted said that they are
nowhere closer to a new contract you
have openly said Odell don't practice we
saw some footage just in the green room
a second ago he's running he's jumping
his legs look great jump now does he
keep practicing well I got no problem
with what I saw their practice like that
do your drills do your individual drills
foot speed right out run running be be
around be in the meetings it's great
that he's there but as soon as it's
seven on seven right
don't do it don't jump up for a ball
Layton Collins might be underneath your
legs by accident he might have stumbled
as he was going to break on the ball and
now he's underneath you and you hurt
your ankle you bought your knee whatever
it is don't even do it I've believed
that him showing up
yeah means that we are closer to a
contract than I think the media is
reporting I think so too I think that if
Odell is showing up he is being told
show up do this and we're gonna get this
done I I would think so yes and I got to
think the Giants they want for his sake
yeah for his sake they want this to go
away he's really done everything proper
other than the little hotel video I mean
which didn't happen this year so yes
exactly it didn't happen this year but
other than that I mean what more can you
say
he's been around there he's been there
for workouts he's at meetings Pat
Shermer has commented that he has a good
relationship a very honest open
relationship with Odell Beckham jr.
already so I think all things are on the
up and up and I think that like guys
like me and Gabe who's moving this
camera around right now
I mean we're gonna go over there with
pitchforks and guns if they [ __ ]
trade Odell Beckham jr. right we're
going right pitchforks unless he goes to
the Niners then you're gonna be
celebrating yeah if this ends up not
panning out well if you guys want to you
guys want to get into our guessing game
don't forget expect net the game is obj
contract we have 214 guesses right now
again I've mentioned Ryan gold before
he's the earliest guest United Kingdom
he's the only one guessing it happens in
May he thinks that Odell gets a contract
this Wednesday the next guest is Andrew
Victor on June 4th and his comment was
this competition was brought to you by
Long Cox Chris Long Fletcher Cox I just
want to read some of these other
captions here whoa big offseason Ryan
macLane guest June 18th and his comment
was I would take a bullet for Chris
Simms
oh thank you I appreciate that June 18th
it's my daughter's birthday too Chandler
Franken felled our friend field from
Minnesota says that Stefon Diggs is
better than Odell Chandler yes we need
to bring you to the site go word psycho
war yes
evaluate your brain then Tim smitten
from Wellington New Zealand says I will
FaceTime from New Zealand to announce
the Bears picked at the Sims and left go
draft party soon as a left go draft
party it's the thing I am having
companies be like do you have people to
promote it and I'm like I work at
bleacher report we're gonna make it
happen but if not but yeah we have 214
guesses right now it's our baby Odell
Beckham jr. we want to make sure our
baby gets paid
we have people loading up on the second
week of June that's what a lot of people
we haven't gotten your official well
whatever the third day of training camp
is we haven't seen because I don't think
they put out the official date yet the
New York Giants do you think that so you
do think we're a little bit do you think
he gets a contract you think he gets a
contract before the season I do okay and
you think he's somewhat close I got to
think that there's at least some basic
parameters being talked about between
agent and an ownership to me that's the
good thing about dealing with the Giants
is I feel like if a member of the
marathon ligo's now we're gonna shake on
this and that word is bond like I
believe them yeah like I feel like an
era family yes would never like I don't
know about the Colts you know I mean I
don't know about the Jets I think you're
read on the Mehra family is a hundred
percent correct Adelle we're gonna do
right by you you do right by us yeah I
feel like the whole family men women
grandmothers whatever it may be they're
the most stand-up owners and football
and people that I've been around they
really are and I will even second that
with mr. Tisch mr. Tisch I don't have as
much of a history with but men it's hard
to find I know big phil simms the big
[ __ ] loves mr. Tisch as well really
yeah I mean he just thinks he's a
stand-up human being he has a lot of
respect for him there I know there's one
other thing I was gonna say there but I
totally forgot so Odell Beckham jr.
contractor did you see this one I'm not
really good at reward you did you see
one of the Marisa
on the podium for justify on Saturday
did you watch the Preakness at all
I didn't the mud and the mutter of his
back your Mudder was a Mudder but yeah
he won again I look I said this before
American marry I guess as part of that
the worst thing that happened to
horse-racing
was a horse won the Triple Crown well
that's wrong it already happened why
don't watch the finals we've seen it
we've seen an NBA team win the finals
not possible the only story for the
troll cranes gonna win well yeah I know
okay but I'm just saying for for horse
racing it was every every intro
thirty-nine years no one has won since
Secretariat could it happen this year
now it's just horses
I don't care oh so it happens twice in
40 years and it's just totally huh this
is this is bullcrap it's rigged it
happens all the time now I heard about
Secretariat my entire heart
three and a half sighs a normal horse he
did know it was sold to me right that a
horse had to be insanely special to win
the Triple Crown which is what American
Pharoah was and is exactly what
justifies their saying so what you're
just gonna take the luster off because
it happened two years ago it also could
be this I worked in the capital of horse
racing yeah and the capital of college
basketball Louisville Kentucky right my
love for both of those things have waned
since I left college basket by a look at
now and I just go I don't see it I know
all the scandals I don't think the
athletes are really that good and
there's like six guys I think are really
gonna be MBA players I'm not that
interested in I get you horse racing
when you're there like when you're there
and you're at Churchill Downs and you're
seeing the horses and you're seeing the
festivities and you're seeing the money
and the drinking and the hats and all
that stuff it's cool but from afar like
I think that I'm just a weird person now
that when I'm in a room of people that I
know have not been paying attention to
horses and they line up and they're like
I think justified it's gonna win and
then in two minutes later they don't
give a [ __ ] anymore as a human I just go
this is all a charade like we've just
all been told the first Saturday in May
to give a [ __ ] about something that we
don't
about for 364 days and I want that son
Saturday I was watching the Sixers game
during the Derby when they lost to the
Celtics I wasn't sweating everyone was
like switching over the horse race you
don't know any of these things they're
horses it's a tradition and they're the
best horses on the planet and I do enjoy
watching it so screw you stating you
like tradition I'd like to burn it up
and start I'm just glad he's alive still
I want to watch it I actually might go
to know that he's alive for the choking
let me give you one advice yes if you're
gonna go to a horse race I've never been
to a big one no don't make the Belmont
you're first it's the most disappointing
so the Pimlico and we're going to
another topic
Pimlico I've been all three and Belmont
our horse races and the Kentucky Derby
is an event Pimlico is in Baltimore yeah
it's a mud pit the the infield is
disgusting the stands there's no reason
to be there this is just me and I'm fine
you talk about Baltimore man Belmont
don't you dare talk about like that
worst worst travel experience I've ever
had go to Belmont
it's just you go to Belmont and there's
people wearing tuxedo t-shirts you go to
the Derby there's people wearing tuxedos
okay that's the difference I get you I
know it doesn't seem the same I guess
it's not it's prestigious I still want
to go Debbie Downer jeez over here
Negative Nancy I'm sorry
crap I honestly didn't know go and watch
the Triple Crown how dare you go watch
one of the Grizz is stupid
they don't where's real shirts or
tuxedos they wear t-shirts dude I went
to the Belmont having gone to the Derby
the year before but I'm wearing like a
seersucker suit and I look at these guys
and they're wearing like t-shirts and
I'm like this guy's up for the Triple
Crown oh man I guess I am a little
negative [ __ ] sorry about that
well if you want to go have a good time
I do my little girl's asking so there
that's my really oh so if you're I can
do it right is it worth going like where
I got the right connections and I'm like
Johnny if you could get that pass for
your daughter's loves horses if you can
get on the back side you can be with the
horses then you go okay it's just the
regular like Stan you're gonna look
around and be like it's three hours to
get on NJ transit but Metro North and
they go stand next to Joey Buttafuoco's
what's your father-in-law say all right
Aaron Donald's not going to be at OTAs -
it's pretty unbelievable that the
Detroit Lions took Eric Ebron and the
next two picks were Odell Beckham jr.
it's amazing and then like Taylor
lavon's right there - and Aaron Donald
like damn it Detroit that what that
Miami game screwed all of us
Aaron Donald guaranteed to get a new
contract
he shouldn't show up at all I mean
please don't know gosh hey yes I think I
don't know what else to say thing about
we're gonna take care of hi no like two
years we haven't heard anything even
close to numbers yet or anything he's
another guy I don't worry about like
Odell like a Tom Brady he's gonna be
ready he takes great pride in his body
and all that he's also at an age where
even if he didn't he's still gonna be
the best built guy in the yes he is he's
a freak of nature but at some point has
to be paid big-time money I mean he and
of course then bringing in and Domenic
ensue what's he making 14 million this
year so that's got to add a little bit
of you know fuel to the fire just that
he wants to be paid those type of
numbers and he will be the they got to
work it out he's a generational type
player I mean he's on pace right now to
be a first-ballot hall-of-famer that's
the type of player I don't think his
contract will be compared to just
defensive tackles or defensive linemen
as a whole I think it it probably needs
to be defensive linemen as a whole why
because I think he classifies more of a
different role than your typical
defensive tackle because of his ability
to actually be a legit every down pass
rusher right on that position and then
as we talk about [ __ ] it up stats I mean
he's he's one of the world leaders in
that and just getting in the backfield
and blue making things happen
so right now he is currently making this
year a base salary of just under seven
million dollars when you look at all of
the guys that are top in terms of excuse
me defensive line base salary right
zekiel Anson DeMarcus Lawrence are both
making 17 because they're getting
franchise tax in Douma consuming 60
point-9 then it goes to coleus Campbell
at 15 and then Khalil Mac at 13.8 ham so
he's gonna get he's gonna he's you can
ask for 18 million a year to him that's
roughly it's fraud what he should be
paid I mean come on if you're gonna sit
here and tell me Ezekiel I'll answer and
demarkus Lawrence who are very good
football players they are not in the
same class as Aaron Donald right now I
mean Olivia Vernon's making twelve point
seven Malik Jackson's making thirteen
point five five Peleus Campbell is
amazing as he is he's not Aaron I think
Malik Jackson's a good guy to talk about
in this thing yeah cuz I go Malik check
since thirteen point five yeah Aaron
Donald's worth seventeen point five
that's right Jackson's like Aaron Donald
from a few years ago almost and not even
as good not exactly right this is now
four years later the market has changed
yeah yeah you're gonna have to pay him I
think in that 1718 range I thought about
this yeah we talked all week about how
gambling is gonna bring so much more
money to the NFL mm-hmm
how much of that money or the players
can say no that's gonna be the big
question because while we hear about
these NFL teams being like I gotta save
my money but if there's an influx of
hundreds of millions of dollars that CBA
that's coming up better take that into
account
yeah and I want the value of the
franchise take into account I'm sick of
all of it I'm sick of it 2.2 billion is
gonna go up because the salary cap
should sky were so it has to go to
because there's the appreciation of the
franchise you're right so I that's
that's gonna be one of the big talking
points for sure is just of course with
gambling all the extra advertising
that's gonna come in with it I got it
imagine that's gonna be right on the top
of the list for the NFL free yeah to the
argument as an owner would be the name
of the organization the logo means so
much more than individual players really
then why does the cost or the value of a
franchise rise when you win a Super Bowl
right because the guys went out there
and wanted yes and you're not taking
care of them but that was something I
thought about is if the set if all this
money comes in from gambling
that's salary cap better skyrocket
big-time I got to imagine a will and it
just it's you know I've already told you
guys 2021 what I said this now for a
year 2012
20:21 right be ready for a holdout
so get your Super Bowls in now Eagles
got one you guys Giants already got one
because if you don't want it by 2020 the
NFL is hitting the reset button that's
my prediction
I think this cba this this difference
I've never heard of players and owners
openly discuss fill in the barracks
getting ready for a really bloody battle
and now there are so many things to
argue about whether it's the freedom of
speech or the money and and salary cap
and now gambling like there's so many
things to argue about and damaras Smith
has been there the entire time
right so it really will be interested it
is I do think the players are educated
now is they never have ever so you're
gonna have players that are truly
informed and what's really hurt the NFL
players in the in prior years anytime
there's been a strike even going back to
when I was 7 years old with my dad it's
the younger guys yes the guys that are
just about to oh I'm a veteran that's
going to get paid they're the ones that
buckle and that's the reason the NFLPA
is not even nearly in the same
stratosphere as like the MLB PA because
just not everybody's making money on an
NFL roster you know it's a short career
to be able to bang your body around like
that and got empires buckle they always
end up walking the line it's it's hard
for a guy like Matt Ryan where maybe the
the the fifth round running back goes
dude I am only got $200,000 and now
you're telling me that I can't work for
two years and then I'm a running back
like my window of being good is
completely closed or the worst ones are
the guys that are like 28 29 who haven't
gotten that big contract yet that's the
thing as the owners can wait a mouse
they can't until they start missing game
checks as then yes just getting you guys
ready for it now cuz it's gonna be crazy
and you know who to come to the players
podcast whoa whoa big offseason big big
offseason for Danny Shelton whoa
my body's adjusting to all the running
man Shelton said it's pretty crazy but I
like it so Danny Shelton's not used to
running that much because I guess in
Cleveland you didn't
but now he comes to New England and you
know he runs a lot one thing he hasn't
run Sims the hill cool I'm just getting
my mind ready for it
we haven't gotten to that part it's
deceiving it doesn't look tough but just
hearing from some of the guys it's not
something you want to mess with that was
something you saw a lot guys under
estimating the hill we talked about it
before the Patriots were on the hill
after every practice
Martellus Bennett said man we were doing
it the week before the Super Bowl Hill
was not being constructed I believe the
year I was there so it wasn't there yeah
this is a recent thing I think so I
think it was being put in right that you
stole this from Jerry Rice so whoever it
was he stole but I mean he'll training
is a great thing for football players I
mean again it's about the ability to
explode be powerful what's gonna build
your legs and brought up more than
running up a hill so here's my question
yes they'd run more than anybody the
Browns traded Danny Shelton because he
didn't fit their scheme yeah and
apparently he really wasn't running
enough is there a chance that maybe they
could have just put him on a different
exercise program and he would have fit
their scheme well yeah we're have
something in his contract about weight
whatever it may be I mean New England's
gonna be all over that stuff there are
I'm guaranteed and he's already talked
about shedding a little weight I thought
a few weeks ago but we're just crazy to
me that an NFL player goes to a
different team and goes they're actually
making me run and I'm going the Browns
didn't make you run probably not like no
I knew this is everybody is shocked by
New England with this I mean this is a
culture shock and that's another one of
the things where we just sat right where
you go why is it everybody copying New
England what are we doing how many times
do we have to see them in the fourth
quarter they're still fresh and your
team's tired and they win just replay
the Super Bowl Castilians you know why
because they have a coach that goes get
on the line after practice oh he's such
a mean guy what a dictator he is he
makes them run after practice yes the
problem with the NFL is everybody the
season starts you're in great shape
everything's great because you've had
training camp all of that and then the
coach has become oh I just want to save
their bodies I don't want to beat them
up right yeah that's ok but to save the
body you have to build it at times and
that's where I think people miss out and
that's where I think a lot of the good
head coaches and organizations realize
that and that's why
you see teams like Pittsburgh in New
England that have men that you just go
Danny Luke's gigantic because they're on
them all the time and it never ends and
they're running when I played for Josh
McDaniels or in New England during
practice after practice whatever it may
be is a huge reason for their success
and their mental toughness so that was
whoa big offseason players are running
this whoa big offseason is coaching
motivation tactics I love what a new
coach comes in the NFL and everyone
gravitates we've seen shovels in the
locker room always dig men remember Dan
Quinn he was out there and he brought
like the military and the Cameron logs
like we carry logs together it's always
like it's always so pound the rock we
had intense there's always little right
I can't do but Steve Wilkes new coach
for the Cardinals apparently he's put a
hurdle in the middle of the locker room
baby to represent the hurdles in the
season ahead this guy's taking it
literally folks he's taking it literally
I love what a coach comes in they put
something to know the locker and that's
what we're standing obstacles of the
season don't forget men it's gonna be
some hurdles I would have its coaches
there they this is the way they are they
can be corny as hell there's no other
way to put it but yes it little things
like that go a long way I would have
rather seen them like put the hurdle
like on the lunch line so it really gets
people think they gotta go up a little
and under hurdle I'll have some chick
tater tots and some french fries go
under a hurdle you know that would have
been funny but I get it yeah it's
anything t-shirts themes of the year
whatever it may be just to kind of unite
the football team whoa whoa big
offseason
Russell Wilson can't sleep tweeted out
this morning woke up hungry
hashtag no time to sleep corny it's so
corny I think he's like Tim Robbins
should call him up he should be on like
one of those Tim Robbins motivational
shows like I think they're like this
email that on that Russell Wilson qb2 Q
beef
like I enjoyed it it was like it was
like philosophy and all that stuff but
he's just a cornball but he that's
genuine that's what makes him amazing
it's a special skill that he can be like
that he's waking up and I think he truly
is a reverse Pacman Jones like what do
you mean like pac-man someone that's
like man I don't need to be like that
I'm a figure it out right I'll figure it
out like he's never gonna be right there
or like I just interviewed Dennis Rodman
Dennis Rodman's like I'm gonna do
whatever I need to do don't worry about
it Russell Wilson's like I must always
be in the zone because if you're in the
zone you're ready to play like he's
never out of the zone never there's no
off season for Russell Wilson he is he
is in hash tag know timeless he is in
franchise quarterback mode all day long
but that's what makes him great and
that's why he's the man and he's
definitely one of the best quarterbacks
in football and he handles himself like
a professional and there's no off-field
issues so why are we so okay when
coaches like Steve Wilkes do corny [ __ ]
like a hurdle in the middle and we're
like that's a coach but what a player is
like I don't have time to sleep hurdles
in life I'm gonna conquer them all we
call them corny I know is it because we
want them to be I think we wanted to be
cool their names we want them to be
right exactly right I just think it's
like man we we love you so much on the
field but your speeches are kind of
corny yeah I don't know what that is
what is it it's just I guess we expect
our players that we idolize on the field
we want them to be everything we thought
they would be off the field it's funny
because and it's the reverse too we get
more upset when coaches like when we see
Rex Ryan get into a fight or we see the
offensive coordinator that's now at the
Browns that was with the Steelers Todd
Haley
he's like drinking and getting stuff
from like that it's very unprofessional
but when we see Gronk out drinkin or
whatever we're like he's enjoying being
a football player so we don't like when
coaches get after it and we like when
players get after it but we don't like
when players are corny but we're okay
with it coaches are corny yeah I think
yeah I just think it says also it's like
a teacher and a student
and you probably grew up where you just
grew up with most of the good players on
your sports teams growing up we're cool
kids yeah and you probably came across
more corny
okay when the teacher gives homework
it's not okay when Josh vendrick's in
the front of the class be like excuse me
excuse me you forgot to get work today
did you did you get my Apple in your
desk
I know that the assignments due in four
weeks but I figured I'd turn it in today
no need for extra credit I'm just here
for organization and calendar skills
Yeah right that's like that's Russell
Wilson [ __ ] but that's why he is that's
why josh is climbing the ladder a
bleacher report Russell Wilson is the
Josh vendrick I got one more whoa big
offseason before we get to Julio Jones
the Cowboys offensive line coach I
believe somebody found a book in which
he wrote about drafting players and one
thing he looks for and the name of the
coaches Paul Alexander and the big thing
for him was catch up yeah he talked
about how the 57 on a Heinz bottle is
placed at the precise spot where if one
taps gently on the tip bottle that
ketchup flows freely from the bottle
even the new plastic squeeze bottles
have that perfect 57 the person who
figured that out was a genius this is
all stuff that mr. [ __ ] Zinder wrote
he then continued when I see a large
football player turn a bottle of ketchup
upside down and pound that it's heeled
with tremendous force yet limited
success I immediately make the mental
note he must either play defensive line
or if he plays offensive line he can't
play for me I'm an offensive line coach
I coached the big fat guys I love them
all i'ma need to be the smartest most
cohesive group on the football field
with all those gaps
there's 437 514 possible defensive
alignments at the offensive line must
deal with I need them to be able to
solve simple solutions what do you think
man I think this [ __ ] is hilarious
I mean it's hilarious my first thought
was I loved it and then my second
thought was that's how you figure out
offensive linemen yeah I know you're
gonna you're gonna deduce it down to a
random moment where someone's hitting
the ketchup now I'm not gonna lie I'm a
57 tapper yeah
or I'm a rigorous shaker but that's
ridiculous
there's so many things that we've seen
that are like this that football is the
most the most there
more judging books by its cover in
football than any other sport I get his
overall point I know what he's trying to
say and we've set it here before - right
I mean offensive lineman or their cows
they're grazing in the field defensive
lineman or Bulls in a china shop yeah
they're ready to go what you want me to
go there no how about I just go here and
and screw everything up and that'll work
okay fine do that oh yeah but he does it
he's a good team as a tackle look at him
he screws everything up offensive
linemen everything he said about being
cohesive being the smartest being able
to solve problems on the go being quick
on your feet all those things incredibly
important I mean there's course cases
where I mean somebody's got to tell you
at some point that that's what the 57 is
for somebody told me that when I was
little did you just figure that on your
own you're I'm gonna hit the 57 I think
this is where they placed it because
this gets the catch about right I'm that
smart somebody got to tell you something
like that my thought is this why is he
eating catch up with this many prospects
is he a at the combine like like they're
in the hotel room they get 15 minutes he
goes hey here's a burger put some
ketchup on it like staring at it like is
he taking these guys on lunch line and
being like Oh burger you want some
ketchup like what are the kids like more
of a mustard guy I don't like ketchup
he's he like [ __ ] I don't know if this
guy's gonna be good or not I don't have
any ketchup I wasn't ready for the the
mustard curveball right like is he just
constantly putting ketchup and no but no
it's just one thing he uses it's another
tool this is the way coaches are this is
they Dave will judge books by its cover
and if they have a preconceived notion
of you they will judge off that notion
whatever it may be
yeah to make it fit what they want a guy
told you like Gruden saw me swing the
golf club like I was chipping a like a
ball like short game like got a pitching
wedge and I was 23 years old and I
didn't give a crap about golf I just
knew how to hit it hard and I went out
there to have a few beers and have some
fun it's all I cared about he was like
trying to judge me what do you mean like
my athletic prowess and I want to be
like you know I was a Division one
basketball player and also could have
been a professional baseball pitcher so
does that that didn't count though how
about we so what was he saying to you
she kept it he obviously didn't ship it
well no no I did not but like I think I
missed the ball the first time like
I went underneath the green oh that what
kind of word in common did you go and
then 1/2 B I don't know the same hand
dye that crossed over all your D B's and
shot the reason their faces yesterday
that's that's the hand I shut the [ __ ]
up you're not an athlete don't try to
judge me on your stupid prowess did you
realize the coaches you did you get that
heat and I did I did says it said
something about basketball like oh
you're gonna judge that I mean how about
the what'd he say he just seek he liked
it he was like oh it makes up for your
lack of Atlanta system your lack of
short game but that's just the way
coaches are we see this all the time we
saw this with Josh Rosen
well the volleyball coach heard that
he's a little bit weird so I'm not gonna
take him Alex Smith was taken over Aaron
Rodgers because Alex Smith held the door
open for his mom he's not he's not as
cocky maybe he'll listen to us more that
was the final determination and you
getting Alex Smith and missing out on
the greatest quarterback to ever play
was holding the door yes
screwed up all your jobs out there in
San Francisco all these stories my
personal favorite buddy Ryan when he was
the DC for the Bears the way he was
raised to decide whether or not he
thought a player had enough toughness
yeah he would watch them brush their
teeth this is from the rich Cohen book
and the reason he'd watch them brush
their teeth that if they started
brushing and left the water running he
knew they came from a wealthy household
and that they weren't really tough but
he knew that if they shut that water off
because they're trying to save the water
from the well then they grew up in a
tougher household and they're his kind
of guy that's what buddy Ryan did is the
water running when you're brushing your
teeth the kind of crap that he's against
your abstract story yeah that these
coaches take to define whether or not a
guy's going to be good
I wonder if he would have still drafted
Reggie if Reggie left the water running
hmm I wonder if that would have done it
mmm so I don't know what segment to call
that but I feel like that's something
that we can own whenever we hear around
the draft these randoms perfect example
this year hmm Hugh Jackson went in this
one's a little bit more but Hugh Jackson
went in and he saw a Baker Mayfield and
Baker Mayfield went to the team event
hey and the whole team went hey and Hugh
Jackson was like I mean he's a leader
that's it that's it it's a one moment to
go hoodie yes got you on him to like
them too so there it goes but catch up
and toothbrushing that's like even more
but there's a lot of these I don't know
if we want to call it like book covers
or something like that cuz judging a
book by it's cover by like that it's a
thing in the NFL more than any other
sport it's it's the truly yeah it's your
without sounding disrespectful you're
more of a piece of meat in a football
than any of the other sports I mean come
on nobody the other sports they don't
make the baseball players get up there
and their jock straps and go let me look
at his body and we're gonna take
pictures in HD and then we're gonna take
this back to our office and put it on
our iPads and put it on our digital
system and we're all gonna sit around
the screen and watch highlight videos
and then we're gonna watch that picture
of him naked in front of everybody and
evaluate but no that doesn't go on in
any other sport no sport knowing along
with like psychological testing and
everything else it's it's insane and
then that's why but it's also why
football is amazing and it's the number
one sport in our country yes it is
alright Julio Jones down by the
schoolyard skipping OTAs yo and it
sounds like it's about contract it is
what do you know I know so I had I had a
friend kind of lead me down this road
during the week we're basically going
you know just basically saying like I
think the whole Julio thing you know
it's not about other receivers it's
about Matt Ryan I'm not like whoa you
know what I never thought about that
you're probably right so I made a few
phone calls there's other people I know
and that's the sense I get that this is
Julio Jones more in the fact of there's
no way Matt Ryan's worth two times more
than me right Julio Jones is what gonna
make 14 million this year I mean a
fourteen point two five fourteen two so
you're telling me that Matt Ryan's worth
more than two of him and I think that's
where it goes and I think that that's
exactly what the situation is and it
should be the situation and he should
ask for more money
yeah well Mara we talked we talked about
this in terms of who did you think of
first and people are like all I thought
of Julio Jones getting Matt Ryan all
that money and now he's sitting there
with a contract that really if he got
cut it's really not costing the team any
money I don't think they're gonna cut
Oh Jones a lot of people were looking at
the salary and going well he's making
less than Jarvis Landry and T Y Hilton
and Sammy Watkins and Davante Adams he's
making money than them but you're also
saying it's more Matt Ryan's the one not
triggering I think all those names
probably bothered him but yeah I think
the end of the day he's going who made
whom did Matt Ryan make Julio did Julio
make Matt Ryan and also to your point I
didn't think about this either when you
get a hundred million dollar contract
you're really being called the face of
it exactly right and they went out there
with Arthur Blank and everyone said Matt
Ryan is the Atlanta Falcons right and
really I would argue that Julio Jones is
the Atlanta Falcons Julio Jones has been
the best player on that team for all
seven years that he's been there not
Matt Ryan when teams like we always go
back to this right when teams break down
the Atlanta Falcons the first thing
they're gonna do is go what's our plan
for Julio what are we gonna do how are
we gonna cover them in all these
different places how are we gonna make
sure we don't get anybody stuck on him
one on one too many times how are we
gonna orchestrate all our coverages to
where we're a little protected by this
guy and then they do that and then he
still goes out from 170 on them system
at Ryan's playing ten on nine because
two of the guys are on holy it's a great
advantage and again we're not here to
take away from Matt Bryan we understand
the quarterback position is extremely
important all that but I understand
Julio Jones feeling that way like what
are you kidding me
and added to that okay let's forget
about the Matt Ryan situation and like
the the stuff I heard there but he
deserves a new contract so what do you
say the people that say that Julio Jones
has three years left on his contract and
he should play it out I say [ __ ] you
that's what I say because I say you know
he signed that a few years back and he
was being paid like he was one of the
top receivers in football and here we
are four years later and you know what
he's still one of the top receivers of
football and he wants to be paid like it
how dare he if how about if you're a top
receipt a top paid receiver and you're
not living up to that do you get cut oh
that's right Dez Bryant why didn't the
Cowboys live up to their end of the deal
I don't get it somebody tell me why the
Jerry Jones and the Cowboys are such
mean people
and they didn't live up to their end of
the contract why tell me why Julio is
better than all these guys he's
definitely it's we like right left coat
we're agreeing that Odell Beckham jr.
Julio and Antonio Brown have three best
receivers in football right yes so you
have like Hopkins and AJ but those three
I think are everybody would go it's one
of those three is the number one guy yes
and everybody else is really good and
yes to that point here we are in 2018
and I oh I'm sorry Atlanta your
franchise receiver still awesome and you
got to pay him Oh boohoo yeah they need
to pay them sorry they're gonna have to
pony up and pay him and Tonio Brown type
money his base salary for the next three
years is ten and a half twelve and a
half an eleven point four that is so far
below what he was making and it's it's
weird we get angry at players for going
I've exceeded my contract yet every one
of these fans at their jobs if their
contract was was really below and they
had extra things put on and they were a
huge part of the company we go we I need
a new contract I'm not being paid up to
the level of my performance but yet with
NFL players we go sign the deal it's the
deal it's the weirdest thing ever I
don't even understand because how much
leverage do you think Julio has I think
he's got a lot I do I think that he's
one of those guys that they might be oh
we're okay right now but when the season
started they're gonna go damn I forgot
how much he impacted the defense he's
he's he's the key to the running game
he's the key to all the other receivers
getting open and of course he's the
failsafe for a Matt Ryan - oh crap
everybody's covered let me throw a ball
ten feet in the air five feet out of
bounds in the Super Bowl oh he'll still
jump over a balcony and toe tap and get
it down it was Eric Rowe
is there a chance that the drafting of
Calvin Ridley added to this I don't
think so I don't think that would affect
him I mean he knows he's a man and that
that money is not going to the Falcons
it does protect the Falcons to a degree
that is that was one thing I thought
well okay oh they got Calvin Ridley
okay sure still a rookie he's still a
rookie and he's not Julio I mean Julio
is again he's one generation yeah I mean
who's who's
who's better in their prime Julio or
Calvin Johnson right who's better who
would you take cuz that's what I thought
of too so Calvin had better straight
ahead speed yeah probably but Moya was
much better at taking short pass right
farm
yak he definitely has the advantage in
yak much harder to tackle yeah I thought
it was more of a gamer even though
Calvin had incredible moments it's close
it's very close I think I would take
Julio I would take wholly over Antonio
Brown but that's just me I would do I
know a lot of people were taken in Tonio
Brown I would take Julio yeah there's a
bigger mismatch exactly corners will
tell you that Julio is harder to guard
yes when you see Julio Jones in person
and not into anything disrespected
Antonio Brown but if you saw it Julio in
person the next Antoni you go oh my gosh
Julio is one of those like guys that
walks in a room and you go oh I get it I
understand why so many thing is too is
like Julio has played hurt so many times
and has played through injuries for that
team and for me I'm realizing not only
is it money I just also think it was the
fact that they went up on stage and said
Matt is the Atlanta Falcons and Julio
Jones set there and went I am the
Atlanta Falcons and I made Matt Ryan
because when I'm not there
the guy is average and we come off as
matt ryan haters and people hate that I
used the word average Matt Ryan I think
for the history of his time in the NFL
has consistently been between the 8th
best quarterback in the NFL to the 15th
best quarterback of the NFL and in the
year with Kyle Shanahan was top 3 right
but I think the rest of his career has
been 8 to 15 which is a very good career
is amazing again don't think it's a Hall
of Fame career I don't think it's a
hundred million dollars in the NFL with
current salary caps and how much the
quarterback position warrants I get it
yes right but I think Julio Jones is
sitting there going you know Jones the
year of his career we go you're
definitely one of the three best
receivers in football matt brien you're
right it's really only been one year
you're you won the MVP which I would
still argue that Brady or Rogers
deserved it win the MVP that year I know
Kyle Shanahan yeah get some more of the
should get some of that credit for what
happened that year so I'm with you and
again it does
like we're Matt Ryan haters no it's the
problem and this is not Matt Ryan's
fault
the problem is is he has a special
talent and Julio outside and he had met
Kyle Shanahan calling the place and all
of the praise went to Matt Ryan so in
that year we spent the year going guys
he has a weapon at wide receiver that's
warranting a double-team and every time
and an offensive coordinator that's
making everybody wide open so we were
just saying we didn't even deserve all
the praise but now Matt Ryan is the only
one that's been financially supported
because of that right and Julio is
sitting there going I got an average
school I have Matt Ryan getting a
hundred million dollars and I have Steve
Sarkisian as my offensive coordinator
and you want me to honor my contract
I've got nothing well yeah exactly at
the base premises he's just got to look
at it and go thirty fourteen thirty
fourteen thirty fourteen pay salary like
we've talked about right like it's just
like are you kidding me like it's like
we used to talk about like is Brock
Osweiler really worth three kam
chancellor remember how we used to say
that rock was getting 18 million in camp
Chancellor's yeah six it's the same
thing are you telling me that Ryan's
worth two to two and a quarter Julio
Jones I do I do think this though yeah
all the people that say that we're Matt
Ryan haters if you ask them who's your
guy on the Falcons they're taking
Holyoke Jones I don't I'm not worried
about that at all yeah I'm on Team Julio
the whole time and I know that this is
getting to a point but look this is what
happens to a lot of NFL teams to the
Seahawks eventually people want to get
paid for being selfless and I'm not
saying Julio's been selfish he did get a
big contract but he's far outperformed
it yeah let's get to a serious topic
let's do something to have a look Rueben
foster we said we want to wait and
there's a reason we said we wanted to
wait
Reuben Foster's ex-girlfriend comes out
and admits to lying so all of these
stories apparently about the abuse and
all of that have been fabricated she
took the stand last Thursday and
recanted allegations that he punt
punched her in the head multiple times
saying she made up the entire story
after he broke up with her you said that
this has happened to other players in
your past
I said let's wait because I don't want
to say they're not trying to be
insensitive
you know in the courtroom she testified
that she got into a fight with two women
before going to sleep at Foster's home
falser dumped her in the morning after
that fighting and she tearfully
recounted this on the stand apparently
she told Reuben foster quote I'm going
to [ __ ] your I'm gonna f your ass up
you're not gonna have a job no more
she also said she stole Foster's money
and put his jewelry in safety deposit
boxes in Louisiana where she's from she
also testified that she stole two
Rolexes and $8,000 from Reuben at one
point she said it was more than eight
thousand
how did she steal the money quote I
stole his routing and account numbers
when he went to jail so one this person
is awful she's bought which is common
with what I've been told
okay yeah - in your mind are you
completely okay with Reuben Foster now
no not completely no no not at all
I mean it still thinks dude there's a
sense of relief for me I get that
nothing horrible has happened all that I
mean Reuben Foster's camp as far as yes
okay now let's try to clear her name
further but I still think it speaks to
the in maturities a little bit of him
and he's still not off the hook yet -
because he's they found a semi-automatic
weapon in his house right so you so
let's then go through that right so but
yes it makes me feel better just from a
human standpoint to go okay good this
guy that I wanted to like is a football
player is not a woman-beater or does not
mistreat women yes and I know they're
not done yet but still at least it looks
better from that stamp and the Niners
have to be relieved I would think
because a lot of people came out at John
Lynch and said why are you doing actions
now my thing is always patience because
that's the reason we have a court system
unless the team has that evidence that
it's like sitting in their facility and
they go we know what hasn't gone to
court yet yes but I don't think they
knew and I bet you Reuben was coming to
them and go and you guys need to trust
me and I'm happy from the NFL player
perspective this happened but that's a
scary situation
scary's that somebody's stealing your
account numbers taking your things and
putting it in there openly saying I'm
gonna end your career that's how easy it
is I mean come on it's as easy is that
you're at you're at the will of the
world sometimes when you're a
professional athlete because you're
vilify you can be Phil if I'd you can be
framed in any which way I have truly
witnessed teammates getting punched to
death by their girlfriend not to death
but like literally girlfriends unloading
on them somebody in the neighborhood
calling the cops because there is a
disturbance yeah the cops coming the
girl then cry witness this the girl
crying now because taking the football
and they arrested the football player
when he did nothing I mean other than
cover his head so he didn't get welts
all over the place there's a number of
reasons so I know that's I know that's
I'm not again not being insensitive just
saying I've seen it both ways
it's the cycle a psychology of a
football player a boxer can't get into a
fight on the street because his hands or
weapons right a football player we
naturally watch them we watch you guys
destroy other humans for our
entertainment yeah and so the the
popular notion is are they going to be
able to control themselves off the field
yeah so you're everywhere you go you're
seen as a walking weapon yeah people
look at a football player and go man can
you imagine if he like really got angry
at us right now like people think about
that stuff I've told my Sean Rogers
story right before I don't know Sean too
fast lineman for the Detroit Lions with
the school thing Abraxas huge man--huge
again Shawn Rogers now the guys like
really in his face Shawn Rogers Cox back
the big left okay which probably weighs
200 pounds I got it he knocked the guy
it was like a movie the guy he hit the
guy square in the face and it was like
he flew up in the air and landed in the
middle of the dance floor and everyone I
call
what the hell where'd he fall from and
everybody was like nice punch to the
music star chart damn the cops were
finding him I witnessed it saw it right
there the guys continuing to push him I
think he might have been like dancing
with a girl that they knew or was one of
their girlfriends or whatever it may be
yeah but he tried to defuse it they came
back they got in his face he even like
tried to go like hey guys I'm good
whatever they continued to push forward
him there came the big left and that was
it and yeah all of a sudden he's in
court and having to deal with that when
he really did nothing and try to defuse
it the one thing that I would ask all of
our listeners because I think we have a
very educated and intelligent people is
we are not saying that all football
players are innocent and we're
definitely not saying that all football
players are guilty but unfortunately
with NFL players unlike MBA and other
sports where I feel like they get a
little bit after the doubt because of
recent storylines that have affected the
league people are very willing to say
that they're guilty immediately I know
to me there were two big waves when
Roger Goodell first took over the NFL
and he had an off season of punishing
arrest tank Johnson Pacman Jones that
was the first time where I felt like
people looked at NFL players as
criminals before it went to court the
second wave was the the offseason of
domestic violence with the Ray Rice's of
the world and all those stories those
individual incidents were awful but I
think what happened was it painted all
NFL players in that brush and now
anytime there's a domestic disturbance
we go there's a problem in the NFL there
are 53 players on 32 rosters that's
3,000 that's not including the 20 on
every team that are on the practice
squad and the dozens to hundreds to
thousands that don't make a roster every
year there's a huge amount there's 15
guys on an NBA roster I know there's
like 20
HL I know it's part of the reason why I
look at the NFL and I go is the meat
market
we just cycle them in and out we cycle
them in and out they're a little bit
more disposable in our mind because
there are so many stories if a guy goes
down a guy picks them up because there's
so many out there but this way of
ruining people's lies before they go to
court all I ask our intelligent fanbase
and our listeners is let's just wait you
don't need a verdict before you go to
court and I think I'm happy that this
happened with Ruben I'm sorry that he
went through it and this his
ex-girlfriend that Ennis that's going
through all this I hope she can finally
get to write to my just this one I'm
happy about because I don't like what
it's like we told you he was troublesome
in the draft prospect we knew that he
was gonna be an ingrate that was gonna
go the NFL and get all hopped up on
money and smack a person and then spend
it like I hate when those come true yeah
I mean I hate when those come true so
happiness didn't ya let's end on a
positive note we used to refer to JJ
Watt as a corny dude but guess what he's
a great dude out corny and us again he
it's at this point now Russell Wilson
where you just go that's who he is JJ
Watt that's just who he is he's going to
pay for victims funerals from the Santa
Fe High School shooting he is somebody
that it's exhausting to do charity
mm-hmm it's exhausting to take yourself
away from your job and to spend it on
other people that's the reason we get so
impressed when people give back because
that time could be spent on family or
friends or relaxation or your job but to
constantly be putting yourself out there
and doing that it really is incredible
and I want to say that JJ for a long
time I thought you were corny but the
true thing is is I think that you're
actually a nice person yeah and I see
the same thing for Russell Wilson I
think you're just a nice person yes I'm
not nice all the time you are not nice
all the time so sometimes nice gets
turned into you're just corny doing this
for attention we see it all the time
it's like we used
Dave Caldwell like we got on him why cuz
he was nice and Bush Jim Caldwell
politely answered questions at the media
conference all he's he's not your rights
on a good enough good enough coach
because he he says please and thank you
yeah so to JJ Watt man I salute you dude
that's it's an incredible amazing he
already won NFL Man of the Year and I
think what's crazy is he's a Hall of
Famer for on-field talent and as I think
his play is going to diminish these next
few years who he's becoming off the
field he might be able to keep that
celebrity and fame because of such being
such a good guy it's pretty cool to see
it yeah he can do whatever he wants
man it's over hall-of-famer right now
even if he never plays again yeah Hall
of Fame really yeah I do
I mean come on some of those years he
put together and I fell defense MVPs I
mean we talked about [ __ ] to play up
stat gosh damn he was one of the
inventors of it there was that year when
he had all those interceptions and
deflected passes and touchdowns yeah
where I was legitimately making the case
that he's the most valuable player I
know you were it was a good case because
it was also like he had he took a team
to the playoffs they had no right to be
there and it was the only defensive
player that actually got it done yeah I
don't remember what year that was I know
I can't remember who the MVP was either
but it was probably Brady yeah either
him or Rodgers it was uh yeah I mean
he's amazing and in fact if he just puts
he's he's probably even right now if he
doesn't play he's in the conversation
for first-ballot hall-of-famer I mean he
didn't play never down
I think he's again he was the best
defensive player in football for like
five years about five years right I mean
it what do you get 22 and a half sacks
Kurt Warner can get in the NFL Hall of
Fame so yeah guys thank you so much a
lot of topics the NFL does not sleep
anymore and if you need people to keep
you up to date it's the players podcast
Sims left Co we're never gonna feed you
[ __ ] we're never gonna feed you the
stories that you think you need to know
but you don't really need to know and
we're gonna go in depth for Sims he's
out homies offender could say good
evening on the lef koe man says good
night we're gonna be back in two days
love you so much
hit us up at Sims a love go holler at
you later